so in the same way
if my friend came to me and said hey Enitza
I'm thinking about trying meth
it looks really good
I might get some energy
you know there's some side effects
but I'll deal with it
I would not support that choice
I totally understand supporting a woman's right to choose
if you go back to this original video
it's about me sitting in the food stamps office
waiting to get approved because I decided to be a Tradway for 10 years
and give everything up and just support this man with my life
and that left me here
a single mom to four kids
one of them is disabled
doing everything on my own
she came to me and said
hey I'm gonna jump out of an airplane without a fucking airbag
I really think I can do it
I got this really cool shirt I can do it
not gonna support that choice
you know what I mean
yes we do all have choices in life
some of those choices are stupid as fuck
and we should have friends in our life that are telling us bitch no
and I'm gonna be that friend for every fucking person that sees me
because it is not wise to give up your autonomy and independence
to support another human being on this planet
you gotta eat
you gotta live
and you're the only person who cares enough about you
to make sure that that happens